welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and black panther wakanda forever
confirms a war between two kingdoms that
will intensify to wakanda being flooded
things are escalating quickly this is
all based on a 2012 avengers vs x-men
storyline in which neymar gets possessed
by the phoenix force and then tracks the
avengers to wakanda and uses those
amplified phoenix force powers to flood
the whole kingdom in the wakanda forever
film i doubt the phoenix force is part
of it really this conflict seems more
based on intervention from the land
dwellers the plundering of resources
like vibranium and wakanda's coziness
with the outside world but really the
question remains how does namor flood a
landlocked eastern african nation that
borders real life uganda a country 3 600
feet 1100 meters above sea level is this
film changing neymar's powers is it
changing where wakanda is or is
something else at play here well based
on some new things we have learned i
think we can actually begin to explain
how even on a planet where a giant
celestial corpse remains in the indian
ocean the physics of this flooding might
make sense namor the submariner is
considered a mutant in marvel comics the
son of an atlantean princess ben and the
human liner mckinsey he has a telepathic
connection with sea life and can fly via
the wings on his feet wings that you can
see in the trailer footage when neymar
is born and when he's an adult but
neymar is not a water bender who could
summon tidal waves namor was really only
able to do that in the 2012 comics
because he was a host to the phoenix
force and the phoenix force can
telekinetically manipulate matter
including water but there is one major
difference that we've learned of so far
with namor that might close into what's
going on here because in the comics
neymar's home is atlantis but in the
film they have revealed it's chalo khan
which is inspired by the paradise realm
from aztec mythology marvel studios
might even do away with calling these
ocean dwellers atlanteans to avoid
confusion with aquaman and the dc films
but hold on to this revision because
it's going to be important later but we
gotta talk about wakanda and its
geography in marvel comics maps of
wakanda have depicted it in various
regions of the african continent a 1973
comic showing it on the west coast of
africa along the atlantic ocean but then
another issue later that year with a
revised map showing it closer to the
indian ocean in eastern africa then a
new map from the official handbook of
the marvel universe vol 1 number 12 in
1983 included a map of wakanda that
placed it in southwestern ethiopia now
in the mcu wakanda has really been
considered somewhere near southwestern
uganda we actually first saw it on a map
in iron man 2 showing various sites of
interest to shield which by the way also
included atlantis or we should now
really presume the gateway to swallow
khan news footage and captain america
civil war depicts wakanda as a small
yellow patch on the map around uganda
kenya south sudan and ethiopia bordering
lake turkana but the black panther movie
art book depicts the country in the east
african rift valley bordering rwanda the
national republic of the congo and
uganda with the real world lake kibu on
the western side so that gives us a few
options of major real-world bodies of
water that the mcu wakanda could border
lake turkana lake kivu even the massive
lake victoria while some of these other
lakes are lay locked lake victoria is
actually drained from its north end by
the nile river which snakes all the way
up through africa through south sudan
sudan and up through egypt into the
mediterranean sea so there is an ocean
link there neymar would just have to
swim from salt water to fresh water and
then gradually ascend from sea level up
to
3724 feet above sea level or
1134 meters all the way up to lake
victoria yeah it's really high up there
now of course neymar could just fly into
wakanda with his ankle wings assuming he
knew where it was because you have to
know exactly where you're flying through
that mountain range to be able to fly
into it from the air but that doesn't
really matter does it because from the
shots in the trailer we do see neymar in
wakanda but he arrives from a beachfront
from the water now the flooding of
wakanda based on this footage is massive
the throne room gets crushed by a tidal
wave meaning it must be huge because
that citadel sits atop mount bashanga
which looks down upon the golden city if
the throne room is getting flooded the
city below must be completely covered in
water as well so we're not talking about
a freak weather occurrence here like i
don't know a rural monroe triggering a
flash flood it's not even raining in
these shots to flood an entire kingdom
you would need the amount of water to be
roughly again to that of utah's great
salt lake which contains 5 trillion
gallons of water so yeah this is closer
to like irwin dropping some elvish to
swamp the nazgul someone must be
magically manipulating these waters to
flood the city we've all heard the
phrase a penny saved us a penny earned
but as anybody who's ever had a pocket
full of pennies knows pennies make for
bulging pockets and weird smelling hands
it's always been obvious that somebody
would figure out a better way turns out
that somebody is upside upside is a free
app that lets you earn cash back on
everyday purchases things like gas
groceries or dinner i know it sounds too
good to be true but it is so easy to use
and it works for me i use it when i need
gas so when my tank is getting near
empty i open up the upside app i search
for a nearby gas station offering a good
deal i claim it and then i head there to
get my gas i can check in or snap a
picture of the receipt and i'm good to
go no special cards to carry or numbers
to remember just upside's app on my
phone anytime i want i can cash out to
my bank account or paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands upside
users are earning more than a million
dollars every week and it has a 4.8 star
rating on the app store to get started
download the free upside app on the app
store or google play use the promo code
new rockstars and get five dollars or
more cash back on your first purchase of
10 or more and thanks again to upside
for sponsoring this video and before you
say well the marvel corpse at tiamat
might have displaced some water on earth
that could have caused wakanda to flood
sure but to flood a landlocked country
at that high of elevation coastal areas
worldwide would have to be flooded for
miles and based on the measurements we
did of tiamat's size he probably should
have done that and then some to earth's
crust mantle core and atmosphere but for
earth to be able to survive at all in
phase four and beyond we just have to
ignore the physics of tiamat the way
many of you i'm sure have ignored a lot
of what happened in eternals now could
wakanda forever be changing where on the
map wakanda is located so that it now
could be along an ocean coastline not
likely the aerial shots of this kingdom
depict it with the same exact inland
terrain that we saw in the 2018 film and
considering wakanda was first introduced
on that iron man 2 map alongside its
eventual rival i just doubt marvel
studios would retcon its geography that
much i actually think the fact that
wakanda's inland might have contributed
to their blindness to the threat that
namor brings they thought they were nice
and safe up in the mountains but they
really weren't and this is why i think
it's significant that this film has
changed neymar's homeland from atlantis
to the mythological talal khan in aztec
mythology telal khan is a mythological
afterlife that absorbs the souls of
those who died via drowning or lightning
or as a result of some natural event
connected to the rain deity it is a
watery grave and the mcu in recent
titles like moon knight ms marvel doctor
strange and the multiverse madness
shanghi and thor love and thunder have
all established the existence of realms
otherworldly dimensions that exist
parallel to our own accessed by
waypoints located in specific geographic
coordinates some accessed by death
tahloe's waypoint is hidden in china the
way point to the north dimension was
torn open in karachi pakistan meanwhile
the egyptian duats wakanda's ancestral
plane and valhalla are all accessed from
really anywhere via death so this way
celalo khan might not be a physical
underwater kingdom as we understand
atlantis to be but rather a hidden
underwater portal from our realm that
leads to a whole other dimensional space
making namor and his people
interdimensional beings who hail from an
aquatic afterlife and since these
dimensions can bend space in comparison
to our realm this could be how neymar
arrives in wakanda by creating a
secondary waypoint from tilalu khan into
the lakes and rivers bordering wakanda
and that portal could be how he dumps a
ton of new water into this landlocked
kingdom i mean multiverse madness showed
how people can travel through the mirror
dimension via any reflective surface
love and thunder showed how people can
travel through the shadow realm via any
shadow and i think neymar is going to
show us how he can travel through talalo
khan via any body of water large enough
that you can drown in because drowning
is how one enters slalo khan in that
mythological framework i know it sounds
wild but there's just a shot of namor
underwater with a glowing orb of light
in this trailer this could be one of
those waypoints i was talking about and
the mcu retconned his homeland from a
physical kingdom of atlantis to this
mythological realm of tlalocan for a
reason and i think it might be so that
neymar can exist anywhere in the mcu and
for people to fear him no matter where
they are even if they're not out on the
open seas like you got a hot tub name
where we're gonna get you you left that
water running while you're brushing your
teeth no more than the sink you thought
you were unscrewing those two contact
lens cases nope that's a double dipping
name or i'm just kidding about those
last ones again i think it would just
have to be any body of water deep enough
for you to drown in because drowning is
the way in and out of tlalocan according
to the aztecs and according to namor hey
let me know how you think wakanda gets
flooded or where you think several
trillion gallons of water would come
from smarty pants follow me on instagram
and twitter at boss following rock stars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you